hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jessica
Lauren Francesca from the channel I want
my Lauren is here right now she is a
very talented actress sketch writer has
so much talent and I watch videos like
hers and then react to them and review
them so my work is just as credible as
hers I deserve all the success I have
anyway so this is the first video we're
doing together and I wanted to get to
know Lauren so I thought we're gonna do
asking hot girls if they masturbate you
know just very casual questions get into
very casual discussions so thank you for
having me on your channel of course yeah
of course I'm glad we can talk about
this let's see what some girls have to
say this is from jinkies TV alright
alright let's do this
um I do oh you don't
you've never masturbated [ __ ] she
totally masturbated yeah like how long
ago when was the last time you know
she's shy but she does say dee dee I
decided transform and economy what I
think yeah okay and the main question
today is often being masturbate huh
she's a masturbator for sure why you can
tell you can tell these about people
there's four girls they probably need to
find releases just a simple question oh
yeah yeah yeah she's gonna be illness
paddy that's public transport what do
you catch trains buses trains
trams and trains trams and trains when
you go to the beach
what kind of footwear do you wear
sandals like thumbs yeah and when was
the last time you masturbate you can't
remember you know like a day
wash you really left what's your
favorite food
that's thick the papen honest oranges
nothing
what you said they've been honest
nice stop Lauren what if you can't get
sex it's my job to say oh it is what are
you doing okay interesting is voting
here nope yeah really
don't believer yeah I don't either sorry
so no come no attractive sauce
masturbating when was the last time you
kissed a dog that's probably about a
week of freedom for three weeks
nice isn't with the guy yep nice what
did you must fight or do speed up for
you there you go there you go
and when we do catch public transport
public transport trains trams and buses
oh my god this is the complicated
quipped confident very confident two
days cool I ever subscribe to his
YouTube channel that's concludes the
interview
like you age I don't know what that is
question
by the model questions Maternity Beach
will calculate inflation and economic
issues of merriment
a completion
Wow
yeah that was definitely the most
interesting video I've ever been asked
to yeah thank you I don't think I would
watch this video on my own really no
really no I think it's a really
interesting topic I really do
ever since you know I started dazzling
myself I that's the my word for
masturbation uh-huh
bedazzled orange sure left its habit
more I know you're like uncomfortable to
be close to me especially after this
video but please just bear with me for
the sake of quality content okay okay
okay not every girl but a lot of girls I
mean will be like that they'll be
uncomfortable to answer that or they'll
say they don't masturbate I think that's
a lot I feel like they're all pseudo
masturbate tend to be more tense why do
they like why are they talking about why
are they interviewing girls about that
it's just like raunchy yeah but it's a
part of your character whether or not
you masturbate what business like
they're just like these poor girls like
oh I'm gonna be on TV and then it's just
like cameras lights do you masturbate
like oh no this is what I signed up for
so if you got that question from a guy
you want an answer I would run you would
run would run Wow I would probably like
kick his camera and be like oh my god I
do not want to be associated with this
at all you are not who I thought you are
I thought you would have totally stayed
women kept answer the question gave
examples I thought oh not class that's
not you that's I know I thought you are
Wow
that's my first impression this is this
is how I make first impression I once
heard Ashley Judd I don't know if you
guys remember that is but Ashley Judd
once said in an interview that she read
a statistic than 90% of girls don't
masturbate but then 90% of girls lie
about that you know so you're a liar you
haven't admitted whether or not you do
it I'm not I'm pleading the fifth on
this whole really conversation you like
Tom Arnold grab your breasts and a
sketch that's a character that I was
playing you should you shook your ass in
front of like a bunch of guys paid not
like because one guy
but a character Oh a character a
character character Wow Wow
but you don't want people to know the
real you know I mean this panic grows
like I don't want to talk about that
stuff on camera and use you oh no oh
yeah yeah I care about that stuff too I
feel like if I don't masturbate at least
once a day I'm probably gonna be like
really stressed out intense and probably
take out my aggression on the homeless
guy what yeah it's just who I am I have
to do it it's a it's a need I mean like
I was intimidated by you coming over so
I was like Veronica can we please do
something because I need to you know let
my shoulders be less tense Oh Veronica
no I'm kidding my girlfriend doesn't
like to do things with me she frowns on
that little girl every girl I've ever
girls I've met that admit that they
masturbate I noticed they tend to be
more chilled out if he's if that makes
any sense okay because a lot of girls I
meet that don't masturbate tend to be
more like tense I don't know they're not
as comfortable with their sexuality a
lot of the time uh-huh I've had that's
just my awesome analysis that I make my
observation of the whole female race
yeah yeah I'm trying to think I'm just
like very scared about making comments
that are like gonna come back to haunt
me one day so I'm I'm pleading the fifth
on this they will come back to haunt you
know they'll like it'll be like in some
Google search don't be just like the
clip of me as a gift looped over and
over and over again I'm just like why
you do know fans are gonna comment on
their opinion on whether or not you
masturbated no guy fans stop it I mean
the comment boxes don't do it I can't I
can't stop you guys from writing down
which you want to write down well I get
like lots of interesting comments more
like tits boobs like the juror have to
like I have like this section of the
comments that I don't allow and it's
like boobs tits and like like you must
have so much spam from that mm-hmm so
much spam porn oh that you should do
porn yeah okay yeah no one's ever said I
should do porn I asked my girl from the
other day if I should do if I could do
porn you know like am I good enough to
do porn I know a little bit on the
heavier side but I feel like I'm really
good at sex so I needed my girlfriend's
opinion and she said yeah she thinks
like do you know if anything will happen
I could totally do point yeah okay do
you think a lot of these girls are I
don't think she's an S let's let's
examine this between the girls here
uh-huh
do you think that most of them are
[ __ ] I don't know maybe maybe
not
the girl who said she's an escort I
don't mean she's maybe she just gets a
lot of sex so she doesn't need to
masturbate I don't know you see I've
talked about the tenseness and her
shoulders seem really tense the more
time
yeah she doesn't seem like a relaxed
individual like she can't hear me my
girlfriend yeah you know sometimes I
always thought she could do like one of
those like webcam things really like
donate money and then you know the troll
like touches herself and I've always
supported her in that career and never
she doesn't want to do it she feels that
pressure her into it I'm kidding I'm
kidding
hey baby can I ask you a question
are you comfortable enough to talk about
if you masturbate or not yeah I feel
like a lot of women frown upon the idea
and feel like it's a private matter how
private feel like it's a private matter
but you strike me as one who might be
comfortable to talk about the subject
hell yeah that's my woman right there Oh
Lauren take some notes from my girl
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel if you're new to it you can
click this button to subscribe become a
reject yeah that's the cool thing that I
call my youtube fan base it's so like so
gimmicky to name your name your fans
they're the super team that's what you
call him yeah so it's not based off your
name you just call them the super team
yeah they're my super team that's cool
yeah oh you guys are my [ __ ] ring why it
was a cartridge it straining my [ __ ]
dream what's up thank you you're welcome
aboard the cops Lauren she does a lot of
fun stuff on her channel primarily
sketches they're actually really good
sketches I've seen a lot of sketch
channels I actually crack up when I
watch her sketches so check it out she
had to have come on the channel because
that's how much better she is than me at
everything in life I've known her for
like a half hour and already she's just
significantly smarter than me yeah
Michell friend Kowski hey you guys are
sick man i love the unique type of humor
you bring to the table
yeah very unique very witty - I would
love a shout out I have a channel called
my name Mitchell Frank Kowski on YouTube
I make movies and short films I even
have an hour long feature that I made
with no budget keep doing what you're
doing man
Mitchell friend Kowski listen dude you
got to stay persistent my friend making
films so important what a great way to
transition into films Lorne back me up
on this one yeah yeah definitely you
should cast him in all your films see be
a porn film maker
yeah film porn you've nothing me in
front of the camera I mean you could put
me and Veronica in front of the camera
she'll be down she'll be down Laura will
do background on it no need to do though
oh boy would you do nudity in the film
uh if it was like orange is the new
black or Game of Thrones or like white
chicks - no Wow Wow you think highly too
high of yourself well listen white
chicks one didn't have me in it well
part two will cuz I'm writing it oh yeah
hopefully the Wayne brothers accept my
script
Mitchell listen I want you to comment on
this video I want you to tell me all the
deep thoughts you have about Lauryn
non-sexual thoughts if you can if you
feel like you have to get it off your
chest
or out of yourself in some way do it see
this is called rapport this is called
rapport